pour débuter cette seconde page culture
de la soirée vous avez la parole seriez
vous prêt à devenir mécène à placer
votre argent dans un monument du
patrimoine par exemple voici vos
réponses
j'aimerais bien pouvoir être mécène
d'une association de défense pour les
enfants les adultes la pauvreté etc
oui j'aimerais bien mais c'est très très
plaisir pour le patrimoine français rui
éventuellement si j'avais les moyens de
le faire et si on peut aider pourquoi je
le fais déjà dans le cadre
d'associations
si j'en avais les moyens énormément même
j'aime large tous que c'est bien il faut
conserver notre patrimoine il faut le
garder absolument donc pour les
personnes qui ont par exemple beaucoup
d'argent permettra à la france de garder
des des beaux trésors qu'ils ne
pourraient pas partir à l'étranger si
j'avais l'argent évidemment jeu j'en
donnerai pour un patrimoine français qui
est magnifique et donc heureusement qu'
on m'a d'ailleurs des mécènes parce que
moi je ne suis pas pour l'instant un
pays comme ça et qu'il réussisse pas
pareil oui oui il faut le garder
c'est donc cette notion de mécénat qui
nous intéresse à présent invités deux
invités un millier de rose ray bonsoir
responsable des relations entreprises
pour le château de versailles et patrice
alors vous m'excuserez s'ils écorchent
votre nom votre armée ni très bien bossé
perméable on saura vous directeur
régional de la société générale l'opéra
royal de versailles qui s'ouvre aux pme
au tpo pmi et aux tpe est le mécénat est
possible aussi pour ces toutes petites
entreprises dorénavant on va expliquer
tout de suite comment cela fonctionne
pour l'opéra royal en fait il s'agit de
pas subventionné mais d'investir en tout
cas dans du spectacle vivant pas dans le
patrimoine véritablement de l'opéra tout
à fait c'est un mécénat un peu différent
de celui du château de versailles
stricto sensu qui a des chantiers
patrimoniaux très important mais pour
notre part nous gérons donc tous les
spectacles vivants dans le château dans
le jardin de versailles et ce mécénat
soutient principalement les activités de
spectacles vivants toute la saison de
l'opéra royal qui rassemble maintenant
88 dates de spectacles par an et toutes
les activités
de danse de
d'opéra de concert de la musique tout ce
qui est tout ce qui est programmé sur la
saison et sur l'année à l'opéra c'est un
club d'entreprises en quelque sorte tout
à fait de toutes tailles le cercle de
l'opéra royal combien d'entreprises
aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui nous avons 12 mécène
membres nous avons créé le cercle
il ya trois ans à la réouverture de
l'opéra royal en tant que lieu de
spectacle stricto sensu et donc les
membres
oui augmente d'année en année
nous avons une dynamique de club donc
les mécènes se rencontrent à plusieurs
occasions de l'année ils se rencontrent
au spectacle évidemment et il nous aussi
des relations privilégiées entre est
entre eux on va voir avec vos l'intérêt
justement pour une entreprise de devenir
mécène auparavant mais ça coûte tout
simplement et puis quelle contrepartie
alors les montants d'adhésion vont de
4000 à 45000 euros
donc l'idée est de pouvoir faire
participer l'ensemble des entreprises à
ce genre d'initiative quand on est pme
tpe on n'a pas forcément les moyens
d'être mécènes à haut niveau dont
l'auteur de 45000 euros ça fait
peut-être un petit peu moins bon ça fait
beaucoup même avec la déduction fiscale
qui est donc de 60% du montant du don
qui est quand même importante en france
et donc à 4000 euros
c'est envisageable pour une pme ou une
tpe d'être mécènes mais nous avons des
mécènes plus importants comme la société
générale à des sommes plus importantes
et donc nous avons un faisceau de
mécènes et différents profils qui sont
kiki qui structurent un peu la ville et
le département parce que ce sont
principalement des mécènes locaux et des
entreprises de versailles de
saint-quentin de vélizy enfants des
environs quoi département pour la
société générale pour la direction
régionale vous y avez adhéré aux titres
de pme au titre d'entreprise globale de
la société générale parce qu'un peu plus
que 250 salariés à la société un petit
peu les deux un petit peu les deux
puisque à titre de grandes sociétés nous
avons un engagement qui est maintenant
très anciens dans le dans le monde de la
musique puisque depuis plus de 25 ans la
société générale et soutient le monde de
la musique par
une fondation qui s'appelle le mécénat
société générale mécénat musical société
générale
mais déjà avant le mécénat nous étions
au très présent puisque historiquement
les chorégies d'orange sonné aussi avec
le soutien en tout cas vont bénéficier
du soutien de société générale de longue
date par le passé donc un engagement qui
est fort pour la société et puis et puis
plus localement
là on n'est plus dans une démarche de
type pme puisque la direction régionale
de versailles montre aussi son
engagement dans le tissu local et dans
la vie locale en participant au soutien
et au cercle et au cercle de mécènes de
l'opéra royal donc société générale qui
est donc mécènes pour cet opéra royal
combien ça va coûter qu'est-ce que tu
présentes pour vous justement en termes
d'importance aussi pour l'image de la
société parce qu'on imagine que c'est
aussi pour ça que la société nous coûte
une certaine somme
ça nous coûte ceci étant ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que le mécénat et aider dans
notre pays et c'est heureux ce qui ce
qui nous permet d'alléger justement
notre participation est donc
d'en alléger le poids mais malgré tout
il est important qu'on ait notre fiscale
importante donc assez schématiquement le
coût réel est de l'ordre de 30 à 40% de
la somme effectivement versées donc
c'est très intéressant et je crois que
ça c'est quelque chose d'important c'est
l'aide des pouvoirs publics pour pour
aider justement les entreprises dans
l'absolu à financer le monde de la
culture
c'est fondamental et pourquoi ce choix
véritablement parce qu'il ya un choix
c'est justement uniquement l'intérêt
fiscal n'ont absolument pas fiscal
absolument pas non non je si vous me
passez l'expression c'est la cerise sur
le gâteau les réductions fiscales ce qui
est important c est un engagement comme
je le disais un engagement dans le monde
de la musique c'est un engagement sans
engagement social c'est l'engagement
culturel de la société générale dans son
ensemble et puis plus localement c'est
un moyen aussi de ma de montrer
à versailles dans la région de
versailles que la direction locale
participe aux actions locales à la aux
actions culturelles locales
c'est un moyen aussi faut pas le
négliger c'est un moyen aussi d'avoir
des contacts avec d'autres entreprises
de la région et c'est particulièrement
intéressant et ce et je dirais le mérite
en revient aussi à l'établissement afin
à l'opéra royal qui réunit justement
régulièrement ses mécènes pour réaliser
ces échanges des échanges qui peuvent
être également fautif y est bien pour
les salariés
le salarié qui ponctuellement ou
l'occasion également de venir voir des
spectacles certains clients qui ont
l'occasion actuellement de venir voir
des spectacles je dirais c'est c'est
presque anecdotique dans la démarche
il faut plus voir cette démarche comme
une démarche d'engagement un engagement
dans la vie locale et dans le monde
culturel local et pour l'opéra royal
s'est véritablement important on va
écouter justement catherine pégard la
présidence du château de versailles qui
nous parle l'importance de cette de
cette subvention en quelque sorte pour
permettre à l'ensemble de ses spectacles
vivants de voir le jour plus que
l'argent qu'on nous donne c'est la
possibilité de faire des choses qu'on
n'aurait peut-être pas pu faire alors ça
peut être acheté un clavecin dont on a
besoin pour l'opéra ça peut être financé
un spectacle qu'on n'aurait pas pu
financer cette année parce qu'on en
aurait pas eu les moyens tout seul et
donc c'est une espèce de plus qui est
apportée par nos mécènes dans ce soutien
à l'opéra royal est évidemment pour
l'instant ce cercle est un petit cercle
il comprend une douzaine d'entreprises
mais je crois que petit à petit on
pourra essayer de l'étendre et que si on
étend on s'engagera dans des évidemment
dans des opérations plus large avec
probablement des retours aussi plus
important pour faire venir des publics
différents
nous avons des mécènes qui envisage par
exemple de donner pour avoir en
contrepartie la possibilité de faire
venir
des publics éloignés des mines des
musées ou des lieux culturels et donc
pouvoir les faire venir assister à ce
spectacle
et moi je suis très attaché à cette
transmission des savoirs et j'espère de
cette manière là par exemple pouvoir
inviter des enfants avoir une
représentation du bourgeois gentilhomme
dont les mécènes nous aurons aider à
faire la production comme ça a été le
cas cette année dans pour le bourgeois
gentilhomme qui était mise en scène par
denis podalydès ici toutes les
réalisations qui voit le jour
aujourd'hui c'est grâce à ses 12 mécènes
en quelque sorte un qui vous êtes
véritablement notamment sur le plan
financier j'aurais juste préciser que
c'est l'unique opère en france a
fonctionné sans subvention voilà tout à
fait alors je dirais grâce à nos mécènes
et grâce à notre public parce que
finalement les deux nous permettent de
proposer des spectacles et des
programmations de grande qualité
la fidélité de notre public la fidélité
maintenant de nos mécènes parce que ça
fait trois ans que ce cercle existe et
il respecte année sur l'autre
oui oui oui et ça c'est très important
le plus difficile ce n'est pas de les
faire venir c'est de les faire rester
aujourd'hui 12 mai scène ce suffisant
nous aimerions aller au delà
effectivement et comme le dit catherine
pégard c'est c'est un gage de c'est un
souffle en fait dans notre programmation
c'est c'est un mécénat de développement
en fait c'est une façon de rendre les
productions plus ambitieuse de faire
venir des artistes de renommée
internationale à la hauteur du lieu est
effectivement de laisser des traces des
productions c'est à dire des captations
des retransmissions au cinéma comme ça a
été le cas pour le bourgeois gentilhomme
de mise en scène par denis podalydès des
objets et à acheter aussi des
instruments de musique c'est quelque
chose que versailles n'avait pas fait
depuis l'ancien régime
donc c'est très important et grâce à nos
mécènes on a acheté deux clavecins et un
orc un orgue positif en dessous du
mécénat en particulier j'avais dit à
écouter c'est à l'étude mais c'est c'est
plus compliqué donc
pour l'instant ce sont les tpe pme pmi
également entre 4000 et 45000 euros à
peu près c'est la fourchette
la société générale qui fait partie de
ces mécènes pour pose la question vous
me répondrez pas mais à quelle hauteur
la société générale s'est engagée à
hauteur significative si je tente plutôt
dans la fourchette
voilà tout sur les 10 euros merci à tous
d'être venus dont vous parlez du mécénat
je vous propose de passer au rappel des
titres de ce 19 février très rapidement
le premier restaurant universitaire
écolo de france cela se fasse sur le
campus de l'ufr des sciences à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
les déchets alimentaires servent à
produire du compost compost ensuite
répartis sur les espaces verts de la
commune de versailles c'était un des
engagements dans le cadre du grenelle de
l'environnement le pôle pilote de
sécurité locale est installé à elancourt
elle son objectif une coordonner les
actions des services de secours et de
sécurité en y associant allez savoir
technique d'une cinquantaine
d'entreprises du secteur sa directrice
sera sur ce plateau
jeudi soir le moyen âge une époque
parfois méconnus toujours fascinante et
qui fait l'objet d'une exposition
actuellement elle en cours et c'est
jusqu'au 27 février
et puis en sport du tir à l'arc avec le
championnat de division départementale
par équipe c'était à trappes à 23
équipes en compétition conflans sainte
honorine qui rafle la mise
meilleur club saint quentinois quatrième
celui de montigny le bretonneux et ce
sujet dédié au tir à l'arc vous allez le
découvrir à tout de suite juste le temps
de vous rappeler que la dernière édition
du 7 8 sport le magazine le quotidien du
sport dans les yvelines est à retrouver
sur notre site internet vendée globe 4l
trophy handball féminin notamment à
l'honneur mais pour l'instant place donc
au tir à l'arc 23 équipes masculines
s'affrontaient ce week-end pour la
première étape du championnat de
division départementale de tir à l'arc
ces championnats par équipes sont
toujours des épreuves particulière trois
arches et doivent tirer chacun neuf
flèches en deux minutes le temps de
tirer donc beaucoup plus court qu'en
individuel il faut réussir à se
synchroniser puisque chacun tiers de
flèches donc faut aller vite
un qui commence à les tirer de premières
flèches ensuite il doit sortir laisser
la place au suivant et ainsi de suite
donc c'est vrai que ça c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut s'entraîner puisse
commencer ses seins des automatismes ce
qu'il faut acquérir des automatismes
spécifique que l'entraîneur ne peaufine
plus le jour j pour ne pas perturber la
mécanique de tir je parle très peu de
technique c'est essentiellement du
mental parce que le car c'est quand même
comme tous les sports un peu 80 80 %
dans la tête les archers de conflans
sainte honorine ont remporté cette
première étape du championnat
départemental montigny le bretonneux
termine au pied du podium et se classe
quatrième
mais lui en cours seulement 10e
prochaine étape au tir à 50 m le 21
avril
je vous retrouve demain 18h mercredi de
nouveaux invités seront en plateau il
sera notamment question de cinéma avec
les dernières projections avec bobine
programmés avant cette victoire finale
du tout est numérique excellente soirée
en attendant